YOU.
BUT FIRST, WHEN TRUMP WINS ON
PRINCIPLE, THAT IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S pH.
"ANGLE."
ALL RIGHT, GIVEN FRIDAY'S KICK
IN THE GUT, YOU KNOW, WHEN THE
PRESIDENT DID TO    DECIDED TO S
PRESIDENT DID TO    DECIDED TO G
PRESIDENT DID TO    DECIDED TO ,
NOT VITO, THAT $1.3 TRILLION
OMNIBUS BILL, THE PHRASE "TRUMP
WINS ON PRINCIPLE" MIGHT SEEM A
LITTLE ODD TO SAY THE LEAST, BUT
BEAR WITH ME.
AMID THE DISAPPOINTMENT THAT A
LOT OF YOU WERE RIGHTLY FEELING,
MYSELF INCLUDED, GIVEN THE BAIT
AND SWITCH ON THE BORDER WALL
AND THE FACT THAT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD GETS FULL FUNDING, I
WANT TO TELL YOU TONIGHT, THERE
ARE VICTORIES ON THE HORIZON,
ESPECIALLY INVOLVING ONE
CRITICAL AREA THAT IS WOEFULLY
UNDER COVERED BY THE AMERICAN
MEDIA IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT,
REMEMBER, RELENTLESSLY PRESSED
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> ON TRADE, WE ARE GOING TO END
THE INTERNATIONAL ABUSE.
OUR MASSIVE CHRONIC TRADE
DEFICITS ARE DESTROYING THE
MIDDLE CLASS AND SHIFTING MONEY
AWAY FROM WORKERS TO LARGE
CORPORATIONS WHO HAVE NO
BORDERS.
>> Laura: ONE OF THE BIG
REASONS WHY HE GOT ELECTED PAGE
AND I'LL TELL YOU, TRUMP'S TEAM,
THEY HAVE BEEN BUSILY
RENEGOTIATING TRADE DEALS AND
KNOCKING DOWN MARKET BARRIERS
THAT HAVE BEEN KILLING OFF
AMERICAN MANUFACTURING AND
HURTING OUR WORKERS.
AND THE GOOD FRUITS OF THIS WORK
ARE NOW EMERGING.
REMEMBER THAT ONE SERIOUS TV
NETWORK LIKE CNN AND CBS, OUR
TRADE POLICY FOR THEM DOESN'T
MERIT AS MUCH AIRTIME AS PORN
STARS, BUT OUR ALLEGED TRADE
POLICY HAS A LASTING IMPACT ON
THE LIVES OF MOST AMERICANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
TRUMP HAS BEEN PRETTY WIDELY ON
TRADE, AND HE HAS MADE
PROVOCATIVE AND BOLD MOVES.
HE HAS TALKED TO LOVE, HE HAS
THREATENED TARIFFS, AND AT
ALMOST EVERY TURN, THE
GLOBALISTS PREDICTED TOTAL
DISASTER.
>> THE U.S. PRESIDENT SAID HE IS
GOING TO IMPOSE TARIFFS ON STEEL
AND ALUMINUM IMPORTS.
THIS IS BASICALLY A BYWORD FOR,
WELL, I MIGHT START A TRADE WAR.
>> THERE ARE REAL CONSEQUENCES
TO THIS THAT HE DOESN'T SEEM TO
APPRECIATE.
>> THIS IS A TOXIC MIX WE ARE IN
RIGHT NOW, AND IF THE PRESIDENT
PUSHES AHEAD WITH THAT, IT IS
NOT TOO FAR A REACH TO SAY,
COULD THIS BE THE THING THAT
PUSHES THE WORLD INTO A PERIOD
OF VERY CONSIDERABLE INSTABILITY
OF VERY CONSIDERABLE INSTABILIT
INSTABILITY.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD.
HOW DO THESE PEOPLE STILL WORK
IN TELEVISION?
I STILL DON'T GET IT.
ONCE AGAIN, THE SO-CALLED
EXPERTS -- I SAY THAT ALL THE
TIME.
THE SO-CALLED EXPERTS WERE
WRONG.
TRUMP'S TARIFFS ON STEEL AND
ALUMINUM PROPOSED TO RAISE
ADDITIONAL TARIFFS HAVE BROUGHT
BEIJING TO THE UNITARY         N
BEIJING TO THE UNITARY         G
BEIJING TO THE UNITARY         T
BEIJING TO THE UNITARY         A
BEIJING TO THE UNITARY         I
BEIJING TO THE UNITARY         G
BEIJING TO THE UNITARY         T
BEIJING TO THE UNITARY         B
BEIJING TO THE UNITARY         E
AND ARE GETTING RESULTS.
THE CHINESE ECONOMIC MINISTER
ANNOUNCED THEIR CONTINUING TALKS
WITH THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
BUT THEY HAVE ALREADY COMMITTED
TO A LARGE, LIKE THIS,
EASING U.S. ACCESS TO THE
CHINESE MIGHT KNOW MIKE MARKET,
TREATING DOMESTIC AND FOREIGN
FIRMS EQUALLY, THE
SEMICONDUCTOR IMPORTS, THAT'S
BIG, AND THEY WILL NO LONGER
REQUIRE U.S. FIRMS TO HAND OVER
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY IN
EXCHANGE FOR OPERATING IN THE
COMPANY.
THE U.S. TIMES IS REPORTING THAT
THEY TRUMP TEAM IS ALSO MAKING
HEADWAY ON TARIFFS AND AMERICAN
CARS AND THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO GAIN ACCESS TO THE CHINESE
FINANCIAL SECTOR.
WELL, FOLKS, SINCE WE HAVE A
$375 BILLION TRADE DEFICIT WITH
CHINA, THIS IS ALL REALLY GOOD
NEWS.
ON TRADE, LET'S REMEMBER, THE
PRESIDENT HAS STOOD ON
PRINCIPLE.
HE STUCK TO HIS GUNS AND HE
COMPLETELY ALTERED THE DYNAMIC
FOR THE BETTER.
AND IT IS NOT ONLY IN CHINA.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS THAT A NEW
NASA DEAL IS IN THE OFFING.
WE SHOULD NOTE THAT
JARED KUSHNER IS WORKING HARD ON
THIS BEHIND THE SCENES.
THEN TODAY, WE LEARNED THAT
TRUMP'S TARIFF TALK HAS BROUGHT
BACK TO    KOREA TO THE BARGAINN
BACK TO    KOREA TO THE BARGAING
TABLE AS WELL.
THINK ABOUT THIS, LESS THAN
THREE MONTHS AFTER HE WAS
ELECTED, PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE IT
CRYSTAL CLEAR WHAT HE THOUGHT OF
THAT KOREAN-U.S. TRADE DEAL.
>> WE HAVE A HORRIBLE TRADE DEAL
WITH KOREA.
EVEN BEFORE WE DO SOMETHING WITH
THAT, BECAUSE WE ARE NEGOTIATING
THE TRADE DEAL WITH KOREA, WE
WILL EITHER NEGOTIATE A TRADE
DEAL OR WE ARE GOING TO
TERMINATE THE DEAL.
>> Laura: WELL, OF COURSE,
THAT HORRIFIED THE GLOBE, BUT HE
GOT SOUTH KOREA'S ATTENTION
BIG-LEAGUE.
TRUMP'S TEAM HAS BEEN PLUGGING
AWAY, YOU HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT
IT, AT A TOTAL RENEGOTIATION OF
THAT AGREEMENT.
THE DEAL WAS APPROVED IN 2012
AND IS THE NAFTA AS A TRADEMARK,
SO IT'S NOT SHOCKING AT THAT IT
OUT TO BE A COMPLETE
NIGHTMARE.
IN THE FIRST FIVE YEARS SINCE IT
WENT INTO EFFECT, OUR TRADE
DEFICIT INCREASED FOR ALL BUT
ONE MONTH, 59 OF 60 MONTHS.
OUR AUTO SECTOR WAS HARDEST HIT,
BUT OTHERS WERE AS WELL.
LAST YEAR, KOREA SHIPPED MORE
THAN $16 BILLION WORTH OF
PASSENGER CARS HERE, BUT WE SENT
ONLY $1.5 BILLION WORTH OF
VEHICLES OVER THERE.
YET TODAY, KOREA ANNOUNCED IT
HAD MADE SIGNIFICANT CONCESSIONS
TO BENEFIT U.S. AUTOMAKERS WHILE
ALSO THEY ARE CAPPING THE AMOUNT
OF KOREAN STEEL THAT CAN FLOOD
INTO OUR MARKET PAID FOR THAT,
THEY ARE GOING TO GET A PARTIALE
THEY ARE GOING TO GET A PARTIALP
THEY ARE GOING TO GET A PARTIALI
THEY ARE GOING TO GET A PARTIALN
THEY ARE GOING TO GET A PARTIALF
THEY ARE GOING TO GET A PARTIALO
THEY ARE GOING TO GET A PARTIALM
THEY ARE GOING TO GET A PARTIALT
THEY ARE GOING TO GET A PARTIALU
THEY ARE GOING TO GET A PARTIALP
THEY ARE GOING TO GET A PARTIALS
TARIFFS.
THIS IS TERRIFIC NEWS FOR
AMERICAN INDUSTRY.
IT IS ALSO GREAT NEWS FOR OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY AS WELL,
BECAUSE REMOVING OBSTACLES TO
COOPERATING AND DEALING WITH THE
NORTH KOREAN THREAT.
IT ALSO SHOWS US HOW TRUMP USES
LEVERAGE.
YOU'VE GOT TO USE THE LEVERAGE
WHERE YOU HAVE IT.
TARIFFS ARE NOT A FOUR LETTER
WORD.
MOST PRESIDENTS HAVE USED THEM.
SELECTIVELY, BUT THEY'VE USED
THEM.
OF COURSE, A FAKE NEWS, THEY
PREFER TO IGNORE THE SUBSTANTIVE
ISSUES, YOU KNOW, THE ONES THAT
REALLY MATTER, AND ALL THE
PROGRESS THAT TRUMP HAS
MADE.
CITIZENS, BY THE WAY, WHO HAVE
SEEN THE WAY OF LIFE, THEIR
STANDARD OF LIVING, DESTROYED DR
STANDARD OF LIVING, DESTROYED DN
STANDARD OF LIVING, DESTROYED DG
STANDARD OF LIVING, DESTROYED DA
PERIOD OF WHAT, UNCHECKED
TRADE ABUSES.
PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR COMPANIES
LIKE STEEL.
>> MY FATHER WORKED AS A SMELTER
FOR 40 YEARS.
HE RETIRED EARLY SO ANOTHER GUY
COULD KEEP HIS JOB.
MY BROTHER, HE WAS LAID OFF AND
HE DIDN'T COME BACK TO WORK.
THIS HAS DIRECTLY AFFECTED OUR
FAMILY, NOT ONLY OURS, BUT OVER
300 OTHER FAMILIES.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
GIVEN IT BACK TO US.
>> Laura: SPEAKING FOR STEEL
COMPANIES, LUMEN AND COMPANIES,
THE FORGOTTEN PEOPLE.
THAT IS WHO TURNED OUT TO VOTE
FOR TRUMP IN 2016.
THEY NEED HIM TO KEEP
CHALLENGING THE WASHINGTON
CORRUPTOCRATS AND CHANGING
POLICIES THAT DON'T WORK.
WHILE THE LEFT-WING RESISTANCE
IS WORKING ON RESISTANCE AND
PORN STARS, THEY SHOULD STICK TO
PRINCIPLES.
IT'S A SHAME THEY BLEW IT ON THE